is the goal in order for America to be
free
to go up against establishment expose
them replace them with people that are
Statesmen and hold them accountable
would you say that should be one of
American voters top goals it is the
essential objective we're on the same
page so now he this course can I add one
little thing of course and I talked a
little bit about this in my talk
yesterday about when you look at the
words that the founders used in our
founding documents We the People a
self-governed nation we are the ones who
have the ability to make this change it
feels hopeless at times because of how
much money and power and all these
machines that are that exist to maintain
that status quo of power but ultimately
at The Ballot Box we are the ones who
have the power to make the kind of
change you're talking about and hold
these elected leaders accountable